yeah welcome to this video playing
vulgar in and I have a string of six
losses I hope I can break that string
but this is a tricky opponent for me and
I don't have a good score against him
okay I wanted to avoid the road open to
doing something else I know we still get
one at least this kind of position yeah
in the in the other games that I played
against him before it was the same story
he plays the ruie with the three
shuffles around there's nothing tries to
win on time and he was very successful
in this way this is probably the same
kind of approach yeah I Plake much
quicker than usual because I'm aware of
this strategy so we just blunders you
for them and let's see if I can just
take the pawn and probably yes but okay
I have lost six games in a row before
and this makes things trickier than
usual even the most them let's say
relaxed individual will be shaken after
six losses I mean I'm not sure shaken I
am but it feels kind of weird having
lost six games in a row in the
five-minute for dropping 100 rating
points okay so he's attacking there and
Bishop age 6 is there is an idea so just
take here maybe I just do this right
if he goes Bishop h6 Bishop h6 rupee for
I have 94 as a tactic okay let's do that
I mean if I think for longer I probably
won't make any better move so i might as
well play quickly
so takes on conf 32 times that looks
check like the way to go giving away a
six but it's a very active position look
do you wanna welcome probably like a
queen a six Ruby one not so sure what
I'm threatening then can also take age
three now look do you want it's it's
really not clear what my thread is but
it looks very normal pinning this night
looks like the right move maybe here I'm
tending Bishop f4 and way to let such a
thing for one moment down maybe Bishop
f4 is a good way to start is Queenie to
you know he does not have Queenie tomb
that sounds good we need to look
everyone is actually winning nice little
trick
this one yeah I thought Quinn h3 now a
threatening a pretty big check made
there but this Bishop is hanging so I
can go to g6 maybe with the tempo and
then take on age 3 a bishop h2 Bishop h2
is just winning ah I could have played
Bishop h2 ok now he's stumbling into
this one let's see look everyone is
still winning right King f1 Queen age
one meat and chain takes I take you
seven winning a piece so this tactic i
saw earlier but I didn't bishop h2 was
much easier ok so it seems that I'm
ending the streak quite a relief
it should be reasonably easy to win yeah
you're already you you're almost here
how skeptical I am it should be
reasonably easy though because his pawns
are also week here um they they cannot
easily form a dangerous person okay I'm
thinking Queen a form for Queen h2 I'm
winning this now or queen trade so how
am I going to do this probably get the
king over
let's still be tricky it gets to be
seven and I'm not winning on the
kingside alone okay you should run out
of moose here then the spawns should
drop and go here
one this is an interesting question how
am i winning now like f6 probably f6 and
cover cover with Bishop deform that's
the best setup
mmhmm yeah that's easiest keeps
everything protected when a king move I
go King be sound and he can move the
beep on David he will run out of moose
white your exam thank God I ended the
series of six losses Wow yeah I miss I
miss something something something good
down oops okay so 94 here check check
and yeah okay the computer is just
saying black wins flat but okay it's
still not still has to be done this is
the right move here and now Bishop h2 I
saw it too late ya bish your age too
late it's just winning very easily hack
wins wins everything I already had seen
that this is losing you to look everyone
so I saw that tactic which is actually
more complicated um but it's still it's
still winning he has no defense there
because if he goes here I still have
that but no I had seen it but okay after
this I had just had this this tactic and
win the peace oh wow very glad to have
ended this this this awful stretch of
losses yeah okay it felt it felt like I
didn't play it the best way technically
but I think it should be a win around
here it's it's fairly easy and he just
runs out of moves after a while ok guys
thanks for watching